Xin Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học
Đỗ Bảo Nam blog video ngày hôm nay Đỗ
Bảo Nam blog sẽ chia sẻ với bạn cách
chuyển giọng nói thành văn bản trực tiếp
trên phần 11 cực nhanh đơn giản và chính
xác
ở video trước lô Bảo Nam rock đã chia sẻ
với bạn cách chuyển giọng nói thành văn
bản trên Google Docs hay còn gọi là vua
ta nghiệm
thi bạn chỉ cần vào phần công cụ
xóa chọn nhập liệu bằng giọng nói
và bạn kích vào cái icon micro để nhập
văn bản bằng giọng nói mình lấy ví dụ
bây giờ mình sẽ được vào đây
theo ông bạn đến với kênh tin học Đỗ Bảo
Nam blog
Và nếu bạn muốn dừng Bạn chỉ cần thích
vào vai ai từng micro
Tuy nhiên trong video này
ở Quảng Nam blog xe chia sẻ với bạn một
cách hay hơn chính xác hơn giúp bạn có
thể dễ dàng chuyển giọng nói thành văn
bản trực tiếp trên phần mềm Word
bây giờ mình sẽ trở về desktop
và mình sẽ khởi động phần mềm một
mình sẽ tạo một cái văn bản mới
thi các bước để chuyển giọng nói thành
văn bản tiếng Việt Bạn thực hiện như sau
bước thứ nhất trên thanh taskbar bạn
thích vào cái phần ngôn ngữ danh ngôn
ngữ của mình đang là ex bạn ấn vào đây
này cho đó là tiếng Việt
như vậy là xong bước thứ nhất rất đơn
giản
bước thứ hai bạn chỉ cần nhấn tổ hợp
phím Windows + h trên bàn phím thì ngay
sau đó bạn có thể chuyển giọng nói thành
văn bản bây giờ mình sẽ Nhấn thử Windows
+ h Xin
Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học đã bỏ
Nam vào gốc
video ngày hôm nay đâu Bảo Nam cốc sẽ
chia sẻ với bạn cách chuyển giọng nói
thành văn bản tiếng Việt
như vậy phần mềm út của mình đã tự động
chuyển giọng nói thành văn bản
ưu điểm của việc chuyển giọng nói thành
văn bản theo cách này bạn không cần phải
dùng thêm bất kỳ phần mềm nào
đồng thời phần mềm sẽ tự động thêm dấu
câu đúng như bạn đọc
Ví dụ
bây giờ mình sẽ đặt một câu hỏi
bạn đã đăng ký Kênh Đỗ Bảo Nam Block sữa
Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký vàng hãy khi click
vào nút đăng kí để ủng hộ Nỗ Bảo Nam
vlogs
Xin cảm ơn
nếu bạn muốn dừng Bạn chỉ cần nhấn vào
phím esc trên bàn phím
như vậy là xong
và như vậy trong nội dung viết vừa rồi
đâu bà Nam báo động vừa chia sẻ với bạn
cách chuyển giọng nói thành văn bản
tiếng Việt trực tiếp trên phần mà buốt
cách này có rất nhiều ưu điểm như độ
chính xác cực cao bạn không cần phải cài
thêm bất kỳ phần mềm nào đồng thời phần
mềm tự động thêm dấu câu theo như bạn
độc ngoài ra chỉ cần bạn sử dụng Win 11
thi với hầu hết các phiên bản Word bạn
đều có thể chuyển giọng nói thành văn
bản tiếng Việt
ảnh và video của mình sẽ kết thúc tại
đây nếu bạn có những câu hỏi cần được hỗ
trợ bạn hãy comment trực tiếp vào thế
giới vỡ này Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video
Xin chào và hẹn các bạn ở các video tiếp
theo
Ừ
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích Bạn hãy nhấp chuột vào nay và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ đâu bà Nam bất đồng
thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà năm
mới Bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nút đăng ký
và chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video hữu ích từ đỗ bà Nam với Xin
cảm ơn các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa Đỗ bà Nam Vlog
và truy cập website đô Bảo Nam vip.com
hoặc kênh YouTube nếu bà Năm blocks để
xem thêm các video cũng như thủ thuật
máy tính tay Producer
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ bà Nam vào lúc chúng
con để cập nhật những bài viết hữu ích
mới nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
Ngày mai bạn ở các video tiếp theo